I think the achievements are fantastic
more than anything else what they tell
me is that we're an organization that
absolutely cares about our communities
and so obviously working across two
district councils but the achievements
are fundamentally rooted in in the
different places that make up our two
districts and so they are all about what
makes a real difference to people's
lives the council strategic plan is our
joint strategic plan which was refreshed
only last year and it focus on the the
obvious areas we would expect us to
focus on in that sense so it's focused
on housing on our economy and on our
environment above other areas in itself
and what that means in reality is how
many additional homes do we need how do
we make sure that hands are more
affordable for people who want to get on
the ladder for the first time or for
older people maybe looking to downsize
in terms of the environment that they're
they're currently living in but making
sure that those homes are where they
need them to be so not simply saying
well yes you can move elsewhere within
the district their whole support network
in terms of their community is where
they are now and so community is
absolutely again part of our strategic
plan in terms of creating thriving
places that have the post office that
have the pub that have all the things
that make community life work and that
leads us into their four jobs as well so
jobs are an essential part of making
sure that we have a higher wage economy
that we may have places that people want
to come and live and work in order to
make sure that our folks our districts
continue to thrive so our biggest
challenge whether we like it or not
remains money we are in a situation as
local government the whole public sector
austerity has been with us for quite a
while now it's not going away and we
need to get used to the reality which is
for local government in particular our
funding is going to have to be the
funding that we generate for ourselves
and not simply rely upon government
grant which is pretty much how we've
received it in the past so that's a
mixture that's a mixture of business
rates and again it's essential therefore
that we have a strong local economy to
make sure that those business rates
continue to be increased in a way that
allows us to reinvest them back into our
places
it's council tax and inevitably our
council is very keen on making sure that
we protect our residents as far as
possible from any kin
tax increases or significant council tax
increases and so more than ever before
it's about how we as local government
can generate new money generate our own
funding and so you'll see from some of
our achievements investing in things
like solar PV has meant not only a huge
return in terms of the environment but
it also brings in cash and so those
kinds of activities have become much
more the bread and butter of local
government now every penny we earn we
reinvest directly back into our
communities the more money we've got
clearly the more we can do for our
communities so we have a unique
challenge for Weber amid suffer because
we've made the decision that we're going
to move out of the two districts in
terms of our headquarters so will be
based predominantly in Ipswich and that
along with other reasons means that we
do have as it were a mini point in time
where you could say well what is it to
be Weber amid stuff again if you're not
even based in the two districts so we
need to work hard to create a brand for
the two district councils the private
sector is very good at that you get a
very clear sense when you think of
particularly multinational or local
companies you name a few such as John
Lewis or virgin or any others and you
immediately get a sense of what it is to
perhaps work for them what it is that
they believe in and what it is that
they're trying to achieve
whereas in local government we
traditionally haven't focused in that
area we haven't thought about those
those terms as it were and yet the
reason more important for me
the sense of what does Weber and what
does mid Suffolk believe in outside of
our politics is critical because we
govern in the same way that the police
policed by consent we govern by consent
and the decisions that our councillors
make on a day-to-day basis are only as
good as the trust and the confidence
that our communities and our residents
can place in those decisions so trust
for me is essential and we can't just
ask people to just this we have to
demonstrate what we believe in and so
brand and values are critically
important and those are certainly things
I expect us to be working on over the
course of the next 12 months or so as
well as obviously our normal day-to-day
job
you
[Music]